une journée de stage pour piloter une
voiture de rallye c'est assez classique
ce qui les moins c'est que les pilotes
sont tous malvoyants ou aveugles une
initiative de l'association des VS DVS
sport auto qui s'est déroulé sur circuit
fermé c'était à Montrichard Val de Cher
la voiture de rallye une Peugeot 106
orange vif adaptée double pédalier et
volant spécifique les a Turquie
et bien donc le siège on le laisse comme
ça ok très bien ceinture bouclée casque
attaché et mince sur le volant place à
l'accélération
aux commandes de cette voiture de rallye
romain malvoyant ils sont 5 tous
déficients visuels à des degrés
différents à conduire à tour de rôle
cette Peugeot 106 et il est ressenti
sont là super bien très très bien très
belle expérience une première mais très
très belle expérience c'est bien passé
des dégâts sur la route donc c'est
génial en plus là la voiture elle a des
sensations vu qu'elle est très
dépouillée moi j'aime plus le côté
manuel parce que du coup j'aime bien
passer du test c'était moi je trouve
super bien épuisant j'adore les voitures
et vraiment c'est pour prendre du
plaisir faire des choses que beaucoup de
personnes pensent que que ce n'est pas
possible de le faire quand on voit pas
le défi est relevé car les conditions
sont presque
identiques à celles d'un rallye le
circuit est fermé la voiture adaptée
avec un double pédalier pour la sécurité
de tous dans l'habitacle le guidage se
fait à la voix par le moniteur copilote
avec une technique bien particulière
si par exemple je veux les faire tourner
à droite on va imaginer une pendule et
donc cette pendule le repère si je leur
dis droite 1 ils vont donc tourner le
repère à une heure vers la droite bon en
fin de compte je suis les yeux du
conducteur la session commence avec le
volant seul puis les pédales et enfin la
boîte de vitesse une première pour les
pilotes mais aussi pour l'association
des vis sport auto qui organisent ce
stage à Montrichard c'est né d'un rêve
en fait d'un rêve que j'avais de
d'accéder à au sport automobile et ce
rêve est devenu une aventure associative
puisque j'en profite mais j'en fais
profiter
Nono pilotes aujourd'hui et là la
récompense elle est là en fait ce
premier stage de pilotage adapté ou
handicap visuel s'achève et ce ne sera
sûrement pas le dernier